what's up i'm chris and you might know
me as buzzfeed's matchmaker you probably
also know that feature on spotify called
rapt which shows you your most listened
to songs from last year i feel like you
can tell a lot about a person just based
on that and i bet you can tell if you're
compatible for dating so we're about to
go to the studio and test this out this
is oliver this is ray uh what's up okay
thank you
oliver you're gonna listen to the
spotify rap playlist from three
different single girls and then based
just on that you're gonna help ray
decide who he's going on a date with
let's get my man a date here
this is christine this is may this is
rena what does your spotify rap say
about you i think i'm outgoing but i'm
also feelsy i saw polo g on your
okay do you think your playlist says
something different from the other two i
think so would they be able to tell i
don't know because i was more into the
chill stuff very productive music
productive
self-exploration kind of music yours is
probably more chill but when the time is
right i'll give you a little hint that i
know how to party and yours is like
overall spicy would you agree i would
say yes ray what do you look for in a
girl i think a personality really
matters to me personality is like you
can't just say oh everything you're
right right i think personality for me
uh constitutes like being open-minded
but also being like adventurous
spontaneous so you can tell how
adventurous or spontaneous someone is
based on their music right i think i
think we can try
[Music]
oh okay very very ambient
it's um spanish oh it's spanish yeah i
feel like this girl is down for a good
time
you know what i mean
and you know i feel like she's got some
sensual flavor sexual flavor
caliente
she seems like a very adventurous person
this is also very very chill move your
body
with the song so he gets a feel for who
this is
is it like this girl's got attitude you
know coupled with the first song that we
heard i don't know if you're ready for
her bro i'm ready for her she knows when
to slow it down okay i got you i got it
is that accurate yeah the question is
are you going to be able to slow it down
with her and i'll say dude i kind of
want to hear the music go away this is
kind of torture but it's kind of hard i
feel like she'd be a tease
okay this one's more acoustic please
tell me you know this song not off the
not off the top no how's the guy with
the goofy headband not knowing these top
10 songs okay so she likes to go out and
party with her with her friends but not
like in a i'm out until five o'clock in
the morning type he's being very
specific she wants to go out she wants
to have like a wine night it could be no
i'm thinking more like she's going to be
hanging out with her girls
she'd like to have a race lung around
her arm you know
i also got the feeling that she might
eat you up
bro this is more like i'm hearing drums
like hans zimmer but same time the way
she's singing it is very very essential
it's like
rey
yo is that my angel bro
she my angel yo she's very might she
might very well be but it's an angel
that's probably gonna eat you like so
she knows what she wants so she you
better know what she wants and be able
to provide for her you know i mean i
feel like i i can i can see her putting
on some makeup some foundation some
contour you know getting ready for the
day getting ready to meet ray for her
date you know what i mean playing one or
two of these songs right before they're
about to get busy and then another song
for when they first wake up in the
morning if she knows what she wants
that's very attractive you know i mean i
feel like it's that she has her own like
independent personality which i really
like based on what i said earlier what
you said like i think she's kind of an
alpha maybe a little dominant ray
describe this girl in three words based
on the information you have three words
sexy dominant alpha oh
i like that
yo this i feel like i'm watching it like
game of thrones kind of like marvel oh
oh
it's very much like you see in an action
scene an mcu okay you know so i feel
like oh maybe she she might be like a
music student maybe she went to
juilliards or um
yo chris this is accurate
maybe she's just like tired of being
single and being like where the hell is
rey in my life you know what i mean like
who knows
okay you've definitely heard this song
before i'm saying that because i've
heard this song before and i live under
a musical rock she'll be at that girl
that the club like literally lyric for
lyric singing
i mean i like that i feel like i think
this is the type of person i feel like
very bubbly yeah i get that a lot like
maybe like a bubbly person she like she
has a lot of energy
like high energy what do you think her
favorite food is her favorite food maybe
her favorite drink maybe she drinks like
boba like she drinks boba i feel like
yeah
i feel like the first one might be a
coffee girl yes yes a coffee coffee girl
for the first one this is scary accurate
what
all pop songs what do you think this
girl does for a living i totally i i
tell you what you're saying i feel like
i guess like i have an idea that there
may be a design student or like an artsy
student right but i feel like people
listen to pop like more generalized they
might do like a corporate job maybe like
consulting like investment banking right
maybe even a software engineer i don't
even know but do you see software but at
the same time i think like she realizes
that that's not what she wants to do
forever either she's making that bag and
then getting ready to make moves i'm
freaked out
what you're portraying to me makes me
feel like she is thinking about how she
can grow as a person how she can you
know find her own passions and i think
that is amazing the fact that they just
listen to a few songs and they can like
understand my life story i feel like she
is trying to spread her wings or she
wants to spread her wings oh i love that
what she needs is a race long on her arm
spread that vision that creativity
i've definitely you definitely heard
this song
no wait maybe not i don't know
like a little girl what spitting some
words and then like a little nursery and
then
nursery rhythm right into oh my god was
a nursery
right but then it drops into like
hip-hop but you can hear the nursery
beats and instrumentals in the
background so she's innocent on the
surface but she's like a bad girl
maybe her innocence is just a front damn
she's just waiting for the right ray to
come along for her to be unleashed she's
trapped in a cage bro dude i feel like
all these girls are trapped
all these girls are like trapped like
they're trying to they're repressed
you're projecting yourself man it could
very well be me projecting us not
actually no [ __ ] that my life is awesome
i love my life no anyways this girl is
like the first girl adventurous okay uh
i would say still more like cautiously
adventurous i'm not saying you gotta
convince her or drag her to come out i
need no commitment but once she takes
that step she'll clear out the dance
floor she's gonna be like she's gonna
show everyone on the dance floor that
she got the rhythm she got the moves you
know but like you gotta work a little to
kind of get her out of her shell
this this is a song that you've
definitely heard it's it's a popular
song i couldn't tell you who sings it
but it's all good what how do you not
recognize the voice
huh you don't recognize the voice
chris brown
all right the focus is not on my
inability to know popular artists it's
to find you a date all right i actually
just discovered this song a few weeks
ago i'm kind of late but i love this one
she's very into pop she's very
interesting she's very into pop i could
be listening to this for the first or
second time and i have a general idea of
what she's singing about i really like
that
it's like a piano piece yeah a little
bit of you know synthesizer voice
i think we found our girl and then we
found our girlfriend i'm gonna assume
it's k-pop i i don't i don't want to
make assumptions i don't know if this is
if this is black pink or girl's
generation he knows this k-pop but i
know this person jams out to k-pop
somebody what kind of picture are you
painting right now i mean i feel like
she's like a very upbeat happy person
like bubbly
who do you want to go on a date with
good question i think for the first girl
you know she's described as very like
alpha dominant very sexy which is really
cool but i think like you know maybe our
personalities wouldn't vibe because she
is a very dominant person and i don't
think i'm looking for someone like that
i think like for the second person she
is like really cool and very fascinating
because she's like working on herself
you know she's trying to go outside of
her comfort zone and i really appreciate
that in person but right now i'm looking
for someone who's just more fun and
bubbly in my current state that i can
really vibe with so i'm going to choose
the third girl
you ready to meet him
yes
[Music]
oh what's up you selected may right here
nice to meet you i'm ray
do you three girls have anything to say
to ray about this assessment of you
yeah i'm gonna send the two of you guys
off on a little mini date you've seen
these videos you know the drill you know
how it works and then we'll check in in
a little bit and we'll see what you guys
want to do after that sure can i take
her to like a cafe or like boba or
something
later okay okay
just go along with it
[Music]
how was your little date it was uh you
guys get married do you get married did
you get married already yo i love you
ray where are you taking her on your
date on a date i swear it better not be
boring okay yeah tell us ray there's
this really cool omakase place if you
want to check it out wait he's actually
giving a serious answer i love it they
look very cute they look very cute like
it was meant to be yeah you guys look
mad cute also i hate that your names are
so similar and your child's either gonna
be named jay or or
tay or kay
i'm just waiting for someone to say some
at the end of the video i don't know and
that's a wrap
that's a spotify wrapped
oh
i'm gonna count my shoulders
no just hey yo bro keep this up you're
gonna be back on this couch in a month
[Music]
you